bonjour alain houpert merci de répondre
à nos questions en direct sur arte
france
le couvre-feu est donc avancer à 18h
dans votre département la côte d'or
comment réagit la population sur place
et les dijonnais notamment le maire ps
de dijon françois rebsamen dit que cette
mesure est infondée et puis le préfet
fabien sudry évoque lui une décision
logique qui vise à éviter un recond
finement qui croire c'est une d une
décision verticale on tire sur la corde
les français ont été responsables on a
vu pour les fêtes de la saint sylvestre
elles ont été calmes il ya eu peu de
voitures brûlées par rapport aux années
précédentes on veut empêcher les fêtes
clandestines
mais les français sont des gens
responsables
le français ce sont des gens qui veulent
conserver leur travail récupérer leurs
enfants pour voir vivre et cette
décision s'est faite sans aucune
concertation
j'ai eu un appel secrétaire général mais
on sentait très bien que la décision
était prise et ensuite j'ai eu un sms du
préfet donc c'est une décision verticale
qui fait au mépris des élus locaux du
territoire pour cette crise du coït m17
échelle de décisions 17 organes de
décision et on vient de le président
vient d'en créer un autre avec 3 35
personnes décider au sort c'est un
mépris de l'emi 6 un mépris du parlement
ça montre que le président n'a plus
confiance en ses députés qu'on valait 35
personnes ça évidemment le comité censés
suivre comité citoyen censé suivre la
campagne vaccinale d'un tirage au sort a
débuté lundi dernier
quel impact cette décision du couvre-feu
avancée pour le commerce et l'ensemble
de la vie locale dans votre département
surtout du côté de de la côte dorée de
dijon 18 heures c'est au veut dire que
les gens pouvant aller je parle au passé
à l'air dans les commerces
après leur travail ils ne pourront plus
le faire donc ils vont s'entasser le
samedi et le dimanche matin donc avec
des problèmes de contamination je pense
que c'est une décision au doigt mouillé
une décision qui n'est pas du tout
responsable ce sont des gens qui fondent
la nation se sont assez pas d'état ni
les discours qui se veulent fédérateur
le sont les gens ce sont des français
qui font naître donc ces mesures on
comprend que vous accueillez mal mais la
population comment est-ce qu'elle le vit
le vbl parce que population c'est la
france c'est une musique et un
département comme la côte d'or est aussi
une mosaïque entre la métropole
les deux villes paul bonnet dijon et les
698 autres communes qui sont vraiment
les gens pour aller au travail ont 60 ac
à 70 km h
matin et soir ça va être une difficulté
une contrainte supplémentaire
il va falloir avoir son attestation nous
sommes comme le seul pays à exiger
d'avoir d'avoir des autos attestations
et on a vu que conseil d'état revenait
sur les 3 et 3 millions d'âmes en il va
falloir réviser 6,3 millions d'amendé et
peut-être les rembourser jeu on est dans
une aporie politique une aporie
complètement technocratique
la démocratie c'est la nation la
démocratie c'est pas la technocratie
si vous étiez à la place de l'exécutif
qu'est-ce que vous proposeriez du coup
tout rouvrir tous reconfigure confiné
partiellement confiance aux français
les français ont besoin d'un homme
qu'ils incarnent et les français sont
ils assez disciplinés justement selon
vous on l'a vu je peux regarder
hier à paris les rues sont vides sauf
justement à la sortie du travail des
habitants
les français sont responsables il faut
arrêter de le prendre les français pour
des gaulois réfractaires on est toujours
des deux phrases assassines et président
de la république les français sont
responsables il faut leur faire
confiance pour arrêter d'infantiliser
les français on vient de voir une
personne vaccinée à dijon puisqu'on sait
qu'a dit jean et les premières
injections dans le département est
également eu les premières doses du
vaccin qui ont eu lieu hier après-midi
dans votre département à brazey en
plaine dans le même temps 118 mer de la
côte d'or ont signé une tribune pour
soutenir la vaccination comment est ce
que vous vous juger la stratégie
vaccinale gouvernementale la barre des
100000 personnes vaccinées devrait être
franchi 1 ce week-end bon déjà c'est un
fiasco puisque nous avons nous avons un
membre de déjà de vaccins un manque de
personnes vaccinées la la la la
vaccination est très difficile
le consentement éclairé qui devait être
et cuite maintenant des pluies qui
n'importe quoi donc on oublie
complètement de dire que maintenant ce
virus on ne connaît mieux que pendant la
première vague
on sait comment réanimer les gens on
sait et on parle des masques on parle
des tests maintenant on parle du vaccin
dont on ne parle pas du traitement le
seul traitement pour ce gouvernement
c'est le doliprane engendrait qu'il ya
des traitements qui marche des
traitements je pense qu'on va dans
quelques mois après quand cette crise
sera terminée revenir et on va découvrir
que certaines personnes avaient raison
que c'est on peut remonter l'immunité
des personnes et en particulier des
personnes âgées qui souffrent à 80% de
deux demandes vitamine d il faut
absolument leur donner de la vitamine d
pour leur donner deux
de la force et de la vigueur et quant
aux seuls médecins nous apprendre je
suis pour les vaccins mais j'ai plus
confiance en ce vaccin qui est un vaccin
qui a été fait dans la précipitation
souvenons nous de l'efi soldes lurel m6
vire où on nous disait que c'était
exceptionnel et on s'est aperçu que
c'était une une duperie complète
il va falloir revenir sur les décisions
qui ont été prises en europe ont été des
décisions qui ont été prises par des
technocrates pas par des messins papa
par des scientifiques
voilà la france et c'est aussi le pays
du bon sens et j'ai l'impression que ce
vaccin c'est une espèce de des ruches
makina pour sauver un état
technocratique complètement des routes
merci alain houpert d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin et sénateurs les républicains de
la côte d'or